même si c'est melissa maulin depuis
cette semaine je pense que je donnerais
personne en disant que ce qui a inspiré
ma chronique c'est vraiment la
mobilisation autour du mouvement black
light mars aux états unis mais aussi au
canada et au québec on a vu des excès de
brutalité policière qui depuis très
longtemps reste est puni ou sont validés
par l'état parle et je joue sont
justifiées et présentement je pense que
la présence du
du président n'en est vraiment pas avoir
une désescalade de ce qui se passe dans
les rues aux états unis au niveau
national cependant ce que j'aimerais
aussi discuter c'est qu'au canada au
québec les premiers ministres ont fait
des déclarations cette semaine et they
will le racisme existe je pense que ce
serait une insulte à l'intelligence
humaine que de dire qu'il n'existe pas
cependant on continue de dire que le
racisme systémique n'existe pas et c'est
complètement faux et on essaye aussi de
dispagne et le canada des états-unis en
disant c'est pas les mêmes pays
cependant lors systèmes ont été bâties
sur les mêmes principes donc
historiquement on voit des européens qui
arrivent sur des territoires occupés par
des peuples autochtones
on voit le vol de ce territoire là on
voit l'instauration de lois de règles de
systèmes qui viennent faire de
population autochtone mais aussi les
populations noires de population
asiatique de population juive des
peuples à part qui ont des lois qui les
sépare il essaie et qui font la
ségrégation autant qu'un bas et aux
etats unis
du reste de la population qui est plus
branché euros sans abri donc ce sont des
lois donc le système crée des lois et on
nourrit justement ce système de racisme
jusqu'à ce qu'on enlève certaines de ces
lois là ils ont dit non le racisme
n'existe plus cependant il existe encore
à travers plusieurs lois mais la
différence c'est qu'à un moment donné
dans l'histoire
l'arbre le tronc du colonialisme s'est
séparé en plusieurs branches on a pu
voir le colonialisme canadien on a pu
voir le colonialisme américain brésilien
tous les pays en amérique on en crée des
branches différentes de forme de
colonialisme
cependant elles viennent pas du même
trop ça doit que la pensée européenne
était la meilleure les autochtones
étaient les moins bons et on importe des
ressources humaines pour faire le labeur
pour nous c'est à dire les esclaves
alors ce système là haut
supra partout en amérique et ont créé
justement la base et la croyance ham
nord américaine ou sud-américaine que
certains peuples sont moins importants
moins intelligent
- capable donc ça fait le racisme mais
la partie du système qui existe encore
fait qu'aujourd'hui mais le jeune
exemple autochtones parce que c'est un
des plus clairs la loi sur les indiens
existe encore les pensionnats les
sixties coupe le fait que les femmes
autochtones sont assassinés
disparaissent 104 au questionnement est
aussi la sur représentation dans les
milieux carcéraux des peuples
autochtones
or au canada sont parmi les plus
nombreux
alors qu'on n'est pas la population la
plus nombreuse au canada et on voit la
même chose se passait aux états unis
systématiquement les jeunes hommes noirs
vont être dirigés vers des milieux
carcéraux parce que ça fait partie du
système américain
alors vous comprendrez que si ça vient
du même arbre si ça vient des mêmes
tranches et un moment donné il faut
accepter que ce système là à infiltrer
un peu partout au créer des effets que
la police sans valider présentement la
police ce sens l'idée haussier puisque
le président 30 encourager à des
violences envers des manifestants est
clairement on voit encore aujourd'hui
des mobilisations où certains hommes
blancs qui sont d'une tranche de droit
qui veulent voir justement une nouvelle
guerre civile qui veulent voir des
violences envers des communautés noires
des communautés autochtones peuvent se
promener après la tombée du dd et
corchia suffisamment et ils peuvent se
promener sans impunité aussi ils ont ils
sont validés la police les laisse pas
son on voit des vidéos constamment et on
voit que si tu es un homme noir une
femme noire
un manifestant pour les droits des
peuples des peuples soient des peuples
de frauder tendance est bien là tu vas
faire partie de ceux qui vont arrêter
qui vont être pro havre et qui vont
subir des violences et les images qu'on
a vu qu'on provoque et justement cette
colère là et bien des images exactement
presque pareil similaires existent au
canada attendent leur bain en 2010 il y
avait
un homme qui s'est fait qui est allé se
présenter à un comptoir infirmiers et
c'est un mythe autochtone on parle de
roméo et oiselets en 2010 et la police a
été appelée pour aider puisque l'homme
était un petit peu désorienté un peu
beaucoup d orienter et cependant il est
morte dans des de façon similaire à la
vidéo qu'on a vu aux etats-unis
c'est-à-dire genoux derrière le dos le
cou et la tête alors vous pouvez
imaginer que pour des peuples qui sont
opprimés des peuples qui vivent cette
violence là quotidiennement se faire
dire constamment que le système n'est
pas raciste
on voit que des gens qui font des
massacres dans des mosquées vont se
faire arrêter et s'en sortir vivants
alors que nous dans des interventions
présentement on en voit énormément cette
semaine c'est incroyable on voit des
femmes qui meurent par des appels de
santé et aider ce qu'on appelle des
world au score c'est à dire d'aller voir
si la femme va bien et elles s'en
sortent morts sept ont des fameux
racisées donc vous pouvez comprendre
l'idée derrière les personnes qui se
sentent menacés qui se sentent en danger
et qui peut-on appeler quand la police
elle-même est un risque pour sa santé
donc on se sent exclue de ce système là
donc c'est un système qui fait vivre un
sentiment d'un racisme de discrimination
cependant nous comprendre et que le
discours vieilles autos temps autour de
la mauvaise pomme la pomme pourrie aps
et je peux dire pour avoir des
interactions avec des jeunes policiers
avec des personnes qui travaillent très
fort au sein de la police qui veulent
faire changer ce système là que ce ne
sont pas tous des pommes pourries
cependant si le système si la maison a
été bâtie sur des fondations pourries
il faut défaire cette fondation il faut
recréer ce système là il faut le
repenser pour que justement tout cette
racine de raciste cité avec la ne
faisait plus dans le système de
protection auquel on a droit en tant que
citoyen mais auquel on ne fait pas
confiance justement parce qu'il est
on peut pas savoir quelle pomme a poussé
sur quelle branche donc vous comprenez
c'est un sujet extrêmement délicat
extrêmement inflammatoires et il faut
écouter les personnes qui ont été
victimes de brutalité qui ont été
bardasser qui ont pas le sentiment
qu'ils peuvent appeler la police ou et
qui peuvent avoir une justice après
avoir des interventions parce que
justement ce système là lors du tout le
temps c'est pas pour toi alors je vous
invite à envoyer des questions vous avez
fait envoyer des commentaires bien sûr
toujours dans le respect est toujours
aussi dans l'ouverture des autres
et n'hésitez pas à partager cette vidéo
c'est des sujets extrêmement difficile
extrêmement émotionnelles extrêmement
personnelle et c'est pour ça que dans
des mobilisations comme dwight matters
un bon moment et constamment en support
en et puis pour ces mobilisations la
alors les hashtag comme black white
matters
il faut aussi les voir comme des
acheteurs qui ne sont pas en compétition
avec in the nightmare aux ailes sont en
collaboration et aujourd'hui on souhaite
à toutes nos amis nos frères nos soeurs
qui sont en mobilisation de d'être le
plus en sécurité de faire cette lutte en
se sachant appuyé alors je fais une
belle semaine